we're back hey if you've been keeping up
with us you know we've been gone for a
couple weeks
our lower thirds are there what oh
whoops
I'm not redoing don't at me if you've
been yeah at me if you've been keeping
up then you know we've been gone for a
couple of weeks sorry if you keep it up
you know we've been gone for a couple
weeks we were obviously confused I said
that three times with like what we're
supposed to be doing here you forgotten
how to run a stream and yeah gameplay I
don't forget where I am in the game but
I think we can figure this out yes
you've had a really busy week of work I
went to Nicaragua so we had to take a
couple weeks off I'm really sorry but
we're back and we're gonna get back into
things right now so the last thing that
happened was I found a painting that a
code on it and I think that code gave me
like maybe this army proof but I know I
got my bow gun this got this bow gun is
new I finally got the chance to like get
it so yeah
I haven't used it yeah if you're binge
watching and just you just watched the
previous episode just now apologies for
the preamble but we're back we yeah you
got you zoomed in on the code on the
painting which was 11 26 I wrote that in
my notepad okay good I guess let's go
there now cuz okay wait wait what do I
need
I have bullets I have a bow gun and bows
I have no Negroes okay I haven't I don't
have a grenade launcher I have a knife
and I have this blue emblem card is that
it is that all I need yeah and I'm fine
in terms of health you have an herb I
have one herb but then I'll then only
gives me three slots okay yeah make
sense you seem good okay I'm just gonna
go for it
sweet all right so I got a [ __ ] I hope
there's like none of those long arms
dudes out here I can't remember like
they started coming out of the woodwork
no I think I'm good okay so I remember
this area a little bit this is like the
upstairs and then I go down that symbols
for dogs because there's a bunch of dogs
out here
number there's that opening in the
bottom of the courtyard no that's where
we that where we got the stuff dogs
behind you wait so I don't want to go in
here ah yeah back toward the camera all
right working on I'm working on it all
right
I read you could you could wipe and we
could start over how long does this take
yeah when you want it to happen it takes
a long time
let's take me down not a great start
kill me kill me it's actually kind of an
interesting thing to see how long it
takes me to die two dogs so we're here
idiot
oh he just bounced off your back you
like Captain Falcon up and beat you
Claire Redfield can take a lot of damage
she's like Lara Croft from 2013 Tomb
Raider apparently we're not as close to
death as we assumed oh I was fine
I meant that okay my health was like
greeny green but alright so I have to if
I am doing this from scratch actually
have to take a couple things out of my
pocket the ink ribs and I think that's
it okay so we're back that's fine now
this time 10 we just started hey
everyone Mary was away okay so there's
some [ __ ] going down in Nicaragua there
was can you believe the odds that I
would plan my vacation right when there
was like a government take down so the
government basically did what American
government did recently where they they
make you pay more for your Social
Security but the people who are taking
Social Security get less so it's
basically a double screw over and the
government is owned by like a president
and then like his [ __ ]
Oh for [ __ ] sake all right just go no
hurt yeah
all right talk get in the fire you dumb
[ __ ] so anyway the president like hired
his wife to like help manage the country
just kind of weird right like he was
like president she was like I'll be vice
president
they were like working together and not
helping they made like some kind of
weird decisions where they basically
like changed but like their version of
like the Constitution and we're
basically like now we can be in power as
long as we want you know like a bunch of
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] that you definitely
shouldn't be able to do and then so when
this thing happened so when this thing
happened with the Social Security the
people were like this is some [ __ ]
uh we are protesting we're protesting a
lot of stuff but this is this is really
what takes the cake oh he had hired her
before the social success so the people
were already mad so when that happened
he sent he did a couple of really bad
moves he sent out the army and the army
[ __ ] killed some of the protesters
including students and one person was a
he was like media he was like just doing
his job with a camera he got shot live
on Facebook yeah I was crazy and then
the other thing that he did was really
shoot he was he took down a media outlet
so he stopped them from me able to go
live yeah which is some real [ __ ] so
the people who are like this is crap and
now the protests escalated like severely
everyone's pissed which makes sense I'm
totally in agreement like support for
the people and they
yes support for the people anyway how
did I do I'll take this so hit that
leave hair okay
okay we
is it this button I could have sworn we
did this it's been a while anyway so the
current status of Nicaragua is shits
going down the president is not cool and
he needs to step down and the people are
basically like you can no longer like
apologize protesters are dead we don't
like you step down like that's where it
came from what do you want me to do it
back in the right time but like now
you're right from here yes I just I just
put the thing in that story of your coup
has been it's fascinating anyway so my
vacation took place like on an island
and a 10-person island like there was no
one on there so I'm [ __ ] there's
other places in Nicaragua like there's
items so I didn't see any of this stuff
I was completely not aware of it and
then one day we went to the mainland and
we're getting ice cream this is true we
were like in an ice cream store I was
like having a cone and don't sorry I
don't use this come back out of the
elevator okay this is where you
originally came from you want to go up
those that ramp that was back there okay
EF one battle one field so I'm having an
ice cream I want to go down here yeah
why is it not working my dumb are you
sure this goes up yeah huh maybe not
can I do it a different way
tell me more go back to the previous
room so nice cream what having an ice
cream
maybe there's like a button in here you
want me to push
I'm fairly certain
what are you looking for there's another
place you can just download card oh
those stairs behind there can I get
through oh yeah
thank you Oh balls all right thank you
it's having an ice-cream and then all of
a sudden like two hundred protesters
like with their faces completely covered
with handkerchiefs and stuff
we're like walking by screaming at the
president and stuff and we were like
let's go and like finished our icecream
and left yeah I'd probably yeah but that
was like my only should I take this yeah
that was my only intro to it and just in
my humble opinion they were not violent
they were just angry
so in here why
hopefully that's less time apart you
nothing cool
it looks like a shotgun whoa it only
takes up one slots room nothing
what door could go somewhere I haven't
really done much I don't think you miss
much the Warriors won first round do
something all right what the [ __ ] is
that what is that
oh that's the you even counted him
before remember he was messing you up no
no that's where you got the submachine
they have like half long arms no no like
I'll do pretty long those are
Bandersnatch --is this is what do i do I
don't know that you were actually
supposed to go through there oh my god
okay okay do I even need to go in there
no
where am I going
I have this bow gun I could take them on
go I don't think you need to be over
here go back to where you came from the
guest room I mean you know you need to
actually go back to the room where you
saw that coat on the skeleton painter
the skeleton P yeah when you look
through the camera did you go in there
yet you might have I did go in there
yeah you should have the painting
I don't I didn't get the painting maybe
you that's me this you hear that yeah
doesn't sound good I don't think this is
the way
there's likes basketball happening in
here
I can climb over this great
this is just the other side of that
rumor though panic says oh yeah can I
shoot them he's right there you see him
[Music]
percent worth it
[ __ ] idiot
there's one still another one that oh
yeah we serious wait until he gets in
the crack [ __ ] he's in the crevice oh me
Mike it's stuck on the other one
probably at least one's gone
yes a little bit hold it closer a little
bit closer you move around try to oh my
god
yes she's enough killing it fine idiots
yes all right cool we just like [ __ ]
absolutely did something good with our
lives
all right so there these are the zombies
yes over there okay see me to go back
the way I came is what you're saying
yeah wait what is in that room with the
zombies I don't know I mean it goes
nowhere after you're in there maybe
there's items okay well I'm gonna shoot
them then okay get to reload I don't
know
all right there's been eight rounds with
there what am i doing did it reload okay
so I'm good again heads down
yeah nice dodge bow [ __ ]
alright cool good I don't know oh I know
how to open those I remember uh okay
don't worry about it yet
okay mental note there are acid rounds
there it's me o w round those will be
important I think those are the BL w
rounds
I'm glad you kill them you have to wear
on them later hey guys hang on chemicals
for gun maintenance that green thing
feels like I should be able to take it
can you not that seems weird [ __ ] I took
a beating
it doesn't seem like it that's I know
you can upgrade the handgun later but
that's well that's one of the one of the
suitcases you have has the hands-on part
of it maybe I have to have it with me I
know you just need to lock pick the
suitcase but you also need to do to that
anytime you see a simple lock I believe
that's a lot okay so I have a lockpick
so I'm fine no no I mean I had well okay
all right well that's it then
now let's go get the skeleton can't
believe I got hurt again I'm so bomb oh
well you gotta go back to the remember
where the skeleton painting room was no
but I feel like we could figure it out
on the military facility it's that
courtyard where the worm is under the
ground
yes he's okay I just there's a lot of
like long armed dudes there so that
makes me a little nervous
oh right
there's a lot of long-armed oh wait
don't go not don't go the way I came
wait you're right I think yeah you're
right sorry you're going the right way
you're gonna yeah I have to dodge the
dog but don't go back up in the corner
go to that door to your right when you
come out upstairs
there's a door to the right the door I
tried to go in the first time we played
this and you were like no no no [ __ ]
dogs
I had a girlfriend stay at my place and
just watch him and that just killing it
yeah she's good she said that he was
great and he was fine but he's so funny
he's very back toward the camera then to
the right in that hallway I remember
them being there me being like I'm not
taking any more of this [ __ ] so sorry
which way
let's toward the camera to the right
okay stage left
so this is the you're coming up to the
room where you've got the bow gun but
you just didn't I don't think we had
enough room to the skeleton beam thing I
don't know member you get the bow gun
but then we use the camera to see the
code on the skeleton page I remember
that part 26 I believe it's the code
there's also is it in here one of those
doors oh I think it's through the other
one actually but I'm curious what's in
this one well that has a red light
now you know the code though
unless this one's just straight-up live
well that's the problem this is the bow
gonna room I think I can't these games
really test my memory don't kill me
yeah this is the bow gun room now you
can put in that code I think that's the
11:26 go
so I already did that but you that
didn't get the Scout I don't remember
even meeting the painting to be honest
with you you definitely do because then
you go back to I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm just saying I don't remember
being like get the painting no yeah
member remember the room passed naked
lady when it's that small doesn't it
look kind of like with an afro you know
rock you know yes Salvador Dali it's the
room past where Steve was in the garage
where there was an empty
oh it's one of those vagina looking I
don't know what to do what do I do
right well let me out hopefully oh my
[ __ ] god I'm dying did you already
get it I think there are health you
already tell me what to do no just get
out of there I guess but that's not what
this is oh it still counts while you're
opening doors I had to turn something
off in there didn't I
no no no no no I think you're fine I
think you just can't go back in there
yeah they're good Mike just maybe the
second floor is gonna blow up
oh yeah it's a lockdown now you're
really close to the garage now I'm gonna
die nah nah nah ah don't get my worm
where's the nearest safe room the dogs
know through there but there's the guys
with the arms oh yeah they normally hit
me at least once the dogs don't do much
damage I think you can get it not the
dogs
oh you're telling me to go backwards the
dogs aren't gonna do that much damn
unless you want to risk going past the
war I'm in a lot of trouble here let's
no let's be risky I'm loving it come
back this way let's just dodge the worm
and then go dude that way get me no they
weren't that's if you're going to the
palace you're going to the garage just
don't get hit by the worm race so left
that way
oh you're slow oh yeah you got swallowed
whole
well not we know what we're doing
you can bring a health with you no no
you did a lot of unnecessary oh yeah
bring a house [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my god that's so [ __ ] upsetting if
I just walked a little faster I would
have made it yep yeah if you weren't
limping you move in all right to the
ladder
these [ __ ] dogs
let's go Poochie I mean through the door
through the door
go killing it textbook you're already
off to a better start
yeah don't jinx it I mean okay so
there's no doubt every time you die like
you do the thing better it's just really
mentally tiring it's like it yeah it's
just it makes you like hey you're Pete
[ __ ] try again yeah but like I get it oh
wow easy [ __ ] got a face full of fart
you know wouldn't be the first time I
live with my dog that's what you meant
birds in my face off with my
Clarification up ahead of time next time
you say something like that something
right okay so Ned loans don't forget
those yeah let's get rid of card okay
and then there's actually unless you
yeah do you think those handgun rounds
are worth killing these three dudes in
the next room fifteen handgun rounds um
so I'm gonna go back in there okay so
only for that but not for anything else
and I'm not going in there
mm-hmm no no that's how you killed those
that's how I killed the thingies and
that's worth it that's worth it okay
okay one second I'm it actually switched
to pistol for these guys because there's
too many of them
nice damn shred numb not [ __ ] around
today buzzer all right cool I hope you
like bullets in your butt yes words
right out of my mouth wait what I
thought I think the net gain of this
room is nothing but you like you said
and you might come back here later
where was the room where I thought they
were playing bball cuz that's the room I
wanna go to yeah that's the one next
door yes is it nope get those renamed
okay before you forget those fine no way
I came from the one on the road yeah but
there's two others one there try that
one this one is this the bad one
no the bad one is in the room with the
gate I remember because I was I was very
upset
wait you already had it
can you see them
now you could see them well I think
they're just walking slowly toward you
because you're not technically thank god
you'd think their arms could reach in
between these blocks yeah that'd be cool
come on you [ __ ] all right it's
readjusts
he's not in your butt but you still it
should go through I think the reason I
was going through before is because you
were actually locked on to him he's not
in the walk to the left just to get him
oh he's right there I guess yeah but I
think they're stopping each other for
the Christ walk that way yeah there you
go
now he's right in the crack get in the
crack [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay I'm going through yeah but I think
they're stopping each other idiots yeah
let him walk over that way farther
wasting a lot of arrows here
yes
[ __ ] they're not there anymore
idiots
god damn idiots is taking way more
arrows
[ __ ] its going through but it's not
hitting them again yeah they keep just
like yeah you got to shoot him before he
gets fully back adjusted no it's just
like by the time I
is that going through balls I'm wasting
light it's music to my ears and he gets
hit but it's so rare I can see his
stupid ass like with the corner of my
eye I can see his head when I can shoot
him see it thank you [ __ ] walk in the
crack jack all right I'll just check out
this [ __ ] get over there and sick of
this
like I'm not let me have this house it's
good all right no what happened okay so
back through here yeah back to the right
door collect the painting run like hell
pass the worm to the ground pass the
worm to the garage and we're back where
I was with like with more health more
health it's this way right yeah yeah
with actually perfect health I have not
been hit yet not even by a doge mary
versus dogs round two suck it sounds
like a rare sort of bird he picked up
some mating calls in Nicaragua oh the
birds the birds they're for real were
[ __ ] insane down they were so loud I
know I'm a city girl but like wow three
four in the morning like they were they
were having a good time out there and
like right outside your windows just
like still partying at four amped who
knows what they do all day
I think bird world's pretty crazy if I
do say so myself to do it
well they're always fighting or [ __ ]
or doing something like they're always
mad is there anything that cabins you
check it well you shouldn't have done
that yet don't do it don't do it I think
you've got them already you just forgot
to get them he is already dead no I
think you've got the herbs that were
strewn about last time
that seat that's worth it and here's the
thing too if there's anything in here I
should take it now yeah I don't think
there is though that's where the bow gun
was quick what's this book did you read
this set dressing miss onsen have you
heard about this all right let's just
get the funny thing now a major motion
picture okay I'm gonna take it yeah what
is this skeleton doing looks like he's a
quarterback right before the snap this
guy yeah Aaron Rodgers skeleton here we
go hmm that scared me so bad the first
time in heaven
Evelyn boys I'm ready for it this time
does he explode into like a thousand of
them like why are there so many gives us
friends Oh boys let me through
do you remember when there was a
countdown and you told me that was a
button on a wall and I spent like ten
seconds trying to hit it and it was no
button on the lot law that was an emesis
right here's being an ass yeah notice
this is not a good game anymore
it didn't age well but I understand the
value in it like I could understand why
people would say like that was fun
and I thought it was fun I just was
really stressed out the whole [ __ ]
time all right so I'm leaving I'm going
left I'm not going to die I got so
speedy run oh [ __ ] run 99 oh yeah it was
my birthday I got it that's right
Reza what's your birthday know it was my
birthday September 22nd nineteen twenty
well this time yeah okay so hopefully
the next piece of the puzzle will
unravel once you put the skeleton
painting in its rightful place where
it's through here yeah nope never mind
sorry door behind where Steve that's
where it came from right no the double
doors where you came from
oh right so I'm going there okay hey I
have an idea get in the Jeep drive out
of here and let's just end the game that
makes so much sense you enjoying this
game okay
[Music]
okay I'm out of let opposed I spent them
all on that guy you have something
reserved don't you oh yeah I have I have
snot in your inventory but yes a bow I
have more why do I need them no no I'm
just saying I thought Curtis warn you in
more than 30 yeah I have a lot because I
used to pick him pick him up like crazy
and I was like I don't want well you
didn't have it vote on Bose I have no
gun in which to use that alive he's
alive I didn't know if you saw that I
might be worth kicking in the face he's
bleeding out of his deep you D blood
deep
all right what am i doing it's kind of
dark I'm gonna L hear okay Ellie or do
you want to see that mouth I keep doing
this instead of doing the quick route to
the max I'm dumb looks like straight
ahead okay do you want to see what's the
other room
or no that's an elevator oh right the
other room is where you want to go
straight ahead this room oh right
I don't know member there was a gold
door in a silver door in the palace okay
Alfred and Alexa Alexa the diorama of
the facility where's the worms not there
the tank is though there's a hole to put
something in oh wait actually Oh I was
kind of kidding but is that the tank I
don't think you could do anything right
now but look at it again where's the
whole day you're gonna tank there in
real it's real life in the game in the
real game life hmm
so oh there's another simple lock here
you should go get the lockpick now cuz I
know how to get the lockpick actually
you do too you just you have to give
them medicine too whatever his name I
can't save
okay half an hour more 20 more minutes
alright what would you like to do so you
have the gold key well yeah if memory
serves that'll get you through a door in
the power in the palace now there's a
safe room in the palace so I could go to
the palace and go to like a couple rooms
and then go save or we could use like
the rest I was so to go get the lockpick
from the dude whom you give medicine to
and then you could I have to go to a
save box to get the medicine to give it
to the dude oh you have to go to save
room anyway well this quickest way the
save room would be is it the palace no
the elevator right here - no no no yeah
right the elevator - cuz you got a he's
in the the elevator goes - where does he
know you don't want to go - uh go in the
elevator I you obviously don't wanna go
in the basement just there's only one
option I think it goes to the second
floor which will bring you right to the
safe room cuz you're like underneath the
dogs right now I believe so you don't
wanna go to basement that's where the
gas is go to second floor that should
bring you up here to save room okay
unless there's like a locked door or
something
Oh Lord hey I killed those things with
the arms but I didn't go into the room
where they were you don't need to right
now yep it Oh God
do you hear that me neither
oh this is where the you you came in
here this is the camera room where you
saw the code oh so I think if you go
back through the door
wait what's through that door I try that
oh yeah sweet so the save room is right
there okay let's do that
oh that's where you that's the courtyard
the dog courtyard right there okay is it
above it or something
no what where are we the other door we
want to go through the door straight
ahead of her right now that one but but
you want to know what this one is that's
above where you killed those two dudes
through the crazy right which is why I
want to kind of like just observe okay
okay I hope I can go backwards that's my
only fear yeah yeah no this is where I
fought that dude no you're a this is
above the chief right now that's the
garage I don't know what you can do from
up here honestly okay unless you could
jump that I like yelled at the guy up
there or something
you did but not like a father thing
going on then go back through there I
want to see if you could jump that gap
just in case
which gap that one
come on
I know what the point of this is I there
was just story there and now I feel like
it's a [ __ ] dead door they should
just had it like disintegrate yeah oh
sweet you also unlocked it great
just checking it off the list now okay
so this is the safe cool the dog dorm
are you gonna eat three this year at all
yeah we are guys doing anything
different yeah we love to talk about it
no okay careful
actually a good thing you said that
sorry actually I honestly have no idea
so we're doing our totally normal thing
we're doing press conference days and
then the three Expo days like normal on
twitch TV slash twitch and I think we're
doing like yes standard [ __ ] like the
whatever the demos the interviews that
you name it you know I'm gonna put these
away because I don't I'm not using them
right keep it bold
yeah I'll keep the gold key because I'm
going into the palace one herb should be
fine hopefully okay should I take some
gun arrows I have enough save bucks but
yeah I'd save
I really don't want to have to do it
again yeah we got 20 more minutes to
save once more anyway sorry I am with
you it's actually not we usually record
later in the day it's like yeah so is my
workout day and I really wanted to work
out it's like the reason it's not a good
reason but is your workout day what do
you mean I only work out like one day a
week because I like never make time for
it and this is my day and you wanted to
record today but I was like I don't want
to record tonight because I recall a
quirk out tonight just do push-ups in
the bathroom like no you don't
understand
I go to one I'm joking I don't work out
very well because I get too bored and
stuff there's one dance class I like
it's called dance party and you just
[ __ ] like dance for an hour and it's
awesome and I like it and it's Thursdays
so I really like doing it I know it
sounds silly but like it's my favorite
day I'm not judging where am I going
like what's the best way to get there
I'm trying to remember what you're doing
right now I'm going to the palace no
don't you want to bring the medicine to
the dude you didn't get the medicine I
didn't I think you're gonna have to head
back to the military facility or though
later
I'd really like to not do it again like
twice so I have to later I think yeah
you're fine without doing this so we're
not gonna do it all right so we're gonna
go to the palace and use the gold key to
do stuff yeah all right
to get to the gold palace I was going to
go downstairs go past the dogs is that
right yeah this way right yes wait a
minute hon bring your map up now that
you unlock this door this might be one
more you could take instead of going
past the dogs you can take the elevator
I know that not the basement that I'll
just put you past the dogs anyway first
floor through the garage yeah you could
avoid the dogs you take the elevator to
first floor and then you're still got to
go best the worm but the first floor
will bring you to the garage this is all
just an effort to avoid the dogs
I mean elevators back dammit I wish you
could just descend into the ground of
America I wish you'd just descend into
the ground a different game I'm just
kidding isn't no I don't mind this game
and I like it I think it's a bit it's
really hard to take a break right it's
like we're getting punished for taking
time off mm-hmm
we're like lost not playing it
consecutive days this should be the
garage
these bright lights especially all right
this should be the garage I just have to
go past the worm oh no
[ __ ] we have to pass those dogs in the
tank yard anyway that's okay whatever
these are easier to hear yeah you're
gonna go to the right yeah left up but
characters right yes here yeah and then
and then I'm in the worm go straight
straight and then straight across the
room yeah but then the
but then smaller girl oh wait
Wyatt bigger door smaller girl yeah just
do that why is everything locked listen
it's fine I don't think he's gonna hit
you anyway
I'm the securely locked door know that
sorry I know I'm just oh yeah
can you press the panel right there huh
walk do you get passed back there nice
well that was not on purpose all right I
don't want to die trying to call an
elevator I got hurt I'm hurt why can't I
go through there caution me I just like
I'm amazed all right so this one says
yellow see how do I get out of here
was there there's no card that you were
supposed to use was there you didn't say
to use a card did it it just said the L
Security checks okay I'm serious
mmm cuz this doesn't take me anywhere
new like I actually don't know how to
get out none of these are ways out of
the [ __ ] base that's smaller door
next to the big one should have opened I
don't know why it didn't did I do it
that locked down make it did I do it
wrong no you do anything wrong I don't
think that's that yellow door should be
open right
should I try again yeah use the herb
though oh just like really confused play
hard key you're missing I was we were
both there I did it
maybe you were a manic or maybe I don't
know whatever okay that makes sense for
a second I thought I oh god yeah so
watch out for the banners I know oh I
think I gate was the other side of the
courtyard with dogs the fire the flames
I fell out I'll let you get past these
there are none here there's a Twitter
account that I highly suggest you follow
if you're into cats at all it's called
black metal cat death metal cats do you
follow it no it's very good it's like
photos of cats that look pissed but then
it's like the flames will come
Satan is rising our time is nigh I don't
know it's really good that's good yes
you couldn't use the key now and get rid
of it
okay I don't remember that but you don't
remember I don't it's just a silvery
door that's not what that says I don't
think well I mean shows what you know
you're thinking about cats are in the
comedic timing I could not have better
so this is save room and the gold
louvered to her they must use my voice
cracking I think it's on the second the
bottom floor I don't think it was the
door I said I think there were other
doors down there there's just a bathroom
down there and I thought that's either
the bathroom back right I always go to
that this is the bad
those are the gold marks right there
yeah what but a but um one of the use
guy vehicle
golde block has been released hopefully
the key is not yeah okay um open you
want to go through there I guess so okay
say whatever did you I also [ __ ] my
neck up recently I slept on it weird
when I got home I think I like used a
pillow that was too all right
I'm uncomfortable message
congratulations on your succession as
master of the Ashford family I hereby
present you with an earthenware vase
according to the Ashford family
tradition as you may know the tradition
first began when a Butler presented a
golden key teacup as a commemorative to
Veronica as founder of the Ashford
family her intelligence and beauty are
legendary second and third master
Stanley and son Thomas were also
presented with a similar teacup the
position of family master then shifted
from Sir Thomas to the twin brothers and
then went to Sir Edward blah blah blah
Gold Cups it was also said words
achievement to make umbrella when Sir
Edward passed away and your father sir
exams exceeded thanks everything sucks
now okay so where's this vase
okay I'm just a lot to soak in here it's
like a naked guy it's the carpet
nevermind Oh God alright this is that
this is a puzzle oh oh it's probably the
order of the family that we just read
about right [ __ ] yeah
okay hold on go back so those are dead
that was Alex okay that was that's
Alexia and Alfred the twins so that's
their dad how do you know they just look
like twins and they're the only twins
yeah Brad haire twins okay cool so that
last right that's I said no like them
grown up yeah Oh is there there's more
plate what I don't know everything about
um so there's a guy with a portrait vase
I don't I mean I it's probably he's
holding tea yeah read that thing again
maybe it'll become clear oh no that was
Veronica right that's gotta be Veronica
she's the only woman so she's the first
he's got to reread that thing I think
okay let's write these down ready yep
okay wait I don't have anything to write
the baby invitation we do I not get to
read it again this isn't it why don't
you where was it
oh no oh it's in your inventory it
should be no I think why are they not
[ __ ] labeled before red it won't let
me pick it go to item that is very weird
oh my god do I really not get to hear it
again like this one yeah yeah it's the
child on the projector film there's a
message ring on the picture there you go
oh it's got to be in your inventory
somewhere stop keep so exasperated
you're making me straight down your file
open it whatever I think it doesn't have
see how these have little tabbies on
them okay you just had it the blue one
the bottom was that was it I'm done I'm
out to new master yeah okay I got it
here we go earthenware vase according to
the Ashford family tradition so was that
the most is that the most recent great
because it's in the beginning of the
letter who is this - this is - Alfred
Alfred as you may know this tradition
first began when a butler presented a
golden teacup to Veronica
Veronica's number one the second and
third master Stanley and his son Thomas
were also presented with similar teacups
it was their hope to achieve glory as
Veronica did before them okay so second
and third were Stanley and Thomas they
both have tea cups write that down
then it shifted from Thomas to his twin
brothers Sir Arthur and Sir Edward go
back to the previous one quick so Thomas
is as a twin Stanley and his son Thomas
so it went to second and third Stanley
would the dude with the twins is the
second one yes Veronica then the dude
with the twins wait because from Sir
Thomas to his twin brother so Thomas is
a twin his dad would be the one holding
the twins Oh from Sir Thomas to his
brother Sir Arthur okay so Stanley
Thomas has a teacup with him okay second
and third Masters Stanley is the guy
with the twins yeah so Veronica twins
dude with teacup or tea set there's
another dude what's he say right I can't
remember
oh no Tommy's got a teacup teacup so go
too so what is his twin brother have his
twin brother was Sir Arthur okay so some
other dude I'll put that down okay and
then and then went to Sir Edward your
grandfather
it was also sir Edwards achievement that
established the large chemical
enterprise umbrella so it's possible
that a word will have some kind of
umbrella [ __ ] in his portrait okay
Edward passed away your father Sir
Alexander succeeded the glorious Ashford
family started the suck but yeah all
right that's it
Alex was the dude up those stairs so
that's the last one all right well
processing all right I don't think it's
gonna like burn you alive
all right what that sounds quick the
vase no him the painting Sherm same
child seen on the projector film trace
the a stash Ford Legacy reveal the true
master first press it again okay sweet
so nothing Bad's gonna happen if we get
it wrong all right so Veronica and then
twins and then dude with a tea set dude
with another tea set I don't forget out
right lady it also tells you right away
if it's wrong so that's good
twin dude I'm sorry
wait did it say who that was no okay
it's the man with the candlestick the
dude with the twins next mm this game
okay so they have red hair that's worth
noting I think cool sweet who's next
dude with tea okay what I wrote okay
this guy has tea okay okay sweet another
dude with tea somewhere okay this guy
has a vase that's later on okay the
vases were the one that in the letter
how about this guy he's red-haired as
well he's got a turd plate I do that
yeah
cool um next I wrote down vase that's
I'm gonna wait this is a Kent mister
candlestick now there is an actual vase
up here did it have a button no okay
now this kid also has a button just to
be clear final one though how do you
know that because it said like trace it
yeah okay try the dude to the this guy
with the he's a plate no you did the
plate already this guy's the vase try
the vase yeah this guy mmm sick now the
final guy this guy handle I don't
remember a candle do I don't remember
candle either who is this [ __ ] try it
now the final dude it's a weird family I
kind of guessed on the plate but it's
not a plate the candle who's this
oh is that Alexia Alexa its Alexia right
mm-hmm all right so there's a floral
earthenware pot what the [ __ ] do you
know I did all this effort to like Rob
this lady now what can you inspect it
sure that's a good idea it's been a
while security isn't wondering what the
[ __ ] I was writing on this badge oh yeah
anyway
kind of ugly very astute of the bottom
Oh took a beetle oh that looks like the
[Music]
nevermind okay well we got something
probably good time to save anyway so we
got to figure out what to do the queen
ant object let's check out its body um
so I didn't keep the vase just so you
know it's weird I don't think you need
you what a weird ass room
alright well is that it do I leave and
there's like nothing else to do in here
alright alright see you losers
good save it Palace room
it was weird what are we doing with this
ant just like have his ant-man I feel
like a couple episodes ago our last
episode or something there was a few
times we went somewhere we couldn't I
think maybe wait to go back upstairs to
where we overheard Alexia hit the silver
key I don't know that does seem to be
the next major objective maybe the ant
will unlock something
interesting very interesting I don't
know if we needed to save again yeah we
didn't really know what was coming you
slept six left well five after this yeah
big good progress maybe a third of the
way through the game I think big old bug
maybe you should keep that in inventory
just a jog remember right next time okay
give me a lot of arrows mean I'm killing
up what arrows I got a lotta you know
what should do next
I just don't have a lot of possibly is
doing it no we don't need to go back I
know we need to go back to the prison
eventually yeah give me the medicine but
I think we go back there how do you
think he's doing okay you probably
should have blood out by know it's been
a while stressful stressful times sweet
it's so bad though like we camera you
know we got a lot done
[Music]
we're back in action we're back probably
for the next few consecutive weeks I
don't think I'm going anywhere
yeah I actually yeah next week I'm going
to Philadelphia who goes to Philly I
know I'm just kidding you know who does
Michelle Obama why you don't know
Michelle Obama does this thing where she
it's called reach higher where she's
like telling kids to sign up for college
so she's doing like a thing in
Philadelphia to talk to students about
signing up for college and we're gonna
go stream it oh you're streaming it I
was I thought she invited you or
something yeah Michelle like called me
up on my cell and was like girl I need
you she owes me ten bucks I straight up
I got an email matter sauce and the
subject line read Michelle Obama and
then the subject line was a phone number
and I called it yeah I mean she was
pretty wasted I got about health and
stuff but now she but she's cool I bet
you she's cool probably yeah but anyway
that's resident Knievel episode resident
resident Knievel code Veronica X episode
six I think I don't know who knows but
we're back for we're back are you gonna
be gone all next week so I'll be gone
Monday through Thursday I'll be back
what we could record Friday okay sweet
if you're watching this it's Saturday
thanks for everybody for joining us
again or for binging myths we enjoy
doing these we're back yes for good
good bye
I've had to fire for like Oh God
faithful for